[Music]
yeah he's a wony honky walking down the
street he looks like a junkie cuz his
arms touch his feet and his pockets are
Cluny ain't he yeah he's walk funy in
his there's
a
red this is a new artist I've come
across Justin moan right mohn he's a new
artist Justin
moan I'm lucky enough to be able to do
what I do for a living when I find
somebody who's an artist I
share what they're doing uh Justin m o n
moan really good play the other one
too this is a an artist out of where is
it Pennsylvania yeah levitown levitown
Pennsylvania and it's someone that I
think I think this guy is coming up I'm
gonna say it right now I'm gonna go out
on a limb I I will go as far as to say
this I think in the next year he's gonna
have you're going to know more about him
than you ever did coming up
soon you're not my son why mom cuz
you're the one why'd you go so far out
of your way to try to kill me
[Music]
mentally outside of Philly Philly they
tried to kill me kill me they drove
through the hilly hilly in may sound
silly silly but really spies Runner
cities Reds and Colts roaming freely
filthy sissies tricky tricky they know
the weakness of Achilles bad dogs never
do feel guilty they work for the piggy
piggy make your head feeling
dizy I mean
Fu the very talented Justin
moan coming out of
levitown Pennsylvania he's an artist
he's a composer writer
singer triple threat guy he's out of
levitown Pennsylvania Justin moan Taylor
Swift in the news again always all the
time Taylor Swift We Can't
we can't get away and we wouldn't want
to why would we want to there's nothing
to get away from We Have It All We Have
Love we have uh you know Intrigue we
have politics dating Travis Kelce the
Super Bowl there sports you
know I I am at the point now where you
know because now the Scuttle butt is
that she's going to one day soon endorse
presid President Biden and the Trump
people are figuring out how
to counter that they're there and
there's all these lurd conspiracies
about you know what is happening behind
the scenes
and so that's where we are we're we're
all fighting for the
affection of Taylor Swift if
you live in this country
you must be
blessed kned if you will by Taylor
Swift um so then I guess the people that
are the Trump people are going at
her risky
move it's a
Gambit because she's incredibly power I
think we give her the country give her
the country why have an election give
her the country she's gotten to that
point now
give it to her stop let's stop
pretending this is a
country give it to her how bad can she
do the president's not really running it
the guy Biden's not even awake in the
meetings the wife is sitting in the
meetings bringing him back information
so at the end of the day it's like how
bad could Taylor Swift do just give it
to her ask her knock on her door and in
one of her homes and knock on her door
and ask her if she has an interest in
being the president of the United States
and if she says no compel her to be the
president but how about instead of
endorsing Biden run in his place run run
we we don't care that you don't have any
experience it is of no interest to us we
don't care just run in his place
and endorsement is
wasting her Capital her social capital
right now is so high that in order to
fully take advantage of it she must run
she must run and announce it go I I
thought about it and I've decided that
the best way to safe guard our democracy
is if I run for president let her do
it
let her do it I don't care
anymore if all let her be the pre if
everyone's just going to talk about this
woman every day all day which is all
anyone does and now I'm doing it because
I've noticed that other people are doing
it what am I going to talk about you
want me to talk about Greek mythology
I'm noticing what's going on around me
what's going on around me is it's a
never ending all day every day
discussion of this
woman and who she likes who she doesn't
like who she thinks is going to be a
good
president and what's her take on the
barbie Oscar snub has she weighed in
make her the leader of the country why
not it it it seems to follow
logically that if you have an unhealthy
obsession with this
person that's rooted I don't know in
what but I you know in in in Nostalgia
and growing up with her and her making
you feel good and the music evoking
emotions uh she's the greatest whatever
it's not true it's not true that she's
the greatest entertainer it's a Beyond
it's not true but it doesn't matter
because nothing matters so make her the
president make her the leader of the
United States of America let her fire
nuclear weapons let her kill the
Palestinians let her do it you know why
because we need
somebody who can put a happy
face on some of the policies that people
are having a trouble
with let her write a song about Gaza as
we bomb them into Smither into uh to you
know as we obliterate it let her write a
song about and how sad it is and people
go you know Taylor wrote that song about
how sad it is that they're being bombed
and they're
dying I mean why not it's it's a it's an
idea it's certainly an idea to have this
lady just take it or just go we're at
this we are at the point now we are at
the point very soon where we're gonna
just hand the country over to someone
someone we're just G to give it to
someone we're going to kind of say we're
just going to continue to do what we do
and you can have it so before it's China
let it be her let it be Taylor Swift I
don't mind
that I do not mind that at all she
challenges Trump she
wins and you know it's just happy we
then you know just s we're singing songs
everybody's in love with her they're
happy we'll still do everything we're
doing we'll ramp it up it'll get worse
we will okay if Taylor Swift is our
president the things we will
do the blood that will spill will be
like nothing you've ever seen and it'll
be okay because it'll be the most
beloved figure on planet Earth I wonder
if she realizes how much power she has
it's probably got to [__] her up
realizing that she could sway
presidential elections you know whatever
she wants to do it's got to kind of make
her go wow I had no idea but she can she
is now the most important figure in
America right now Taylor
Swift it's that's it there's this is by
the way this is not any type of
exaggeration Taylor Swift at this moment
in time is the most important figure
culturally in our country there's nobody
I don't know how this Happ it happened
without my involvement or knowledge I'm
just reacting to it and I'm going with
it I'm going with it I'm I'm going with
it I'm asking you to deliver the country
to her give it to her now give it to her
I'm asking you to do it I'm asking you
to do it please so that there's a reason
that I let her and Travis Kelce live in
a White House and and and fire uh drone
strikes at our enemies the hoies and all
these other let them do it let have the
CIA come in and say Madam president and
she'll say call me Taylor and that's her
new album her new album's called call me
Taylor and Caris swisser and the rest of
these people whose brains have been
eaten uh
like fermented alcohol just you know
what I mean like a fruit rotting their
brains have gone they can all go and you
know what you know what the you know why
her new album is called call me Taylor
because the CIA director came in to give
her a a briefing the presidential Daily
Briefing the pdb and you know she just
sat there and she was looking so smart
and she just looked at him and she said
call me Taylor and he was amazed by that
because she doesn't even that that's how
big she is she doesn't even need the
title do it give it to her give it to
her I I I will not resist I will not
resist I will cheerlead for her I
because we want to live in North Korea
we want it with like all all of our the
we want our loyal are our this woman our
undying obsession with this woman proves
that we really want to live in North
Korea let's do it give it to them give
it to them they want the people out
there that you see on the chickfila line
that loops around and around and around
it keeps going or the In-N-Out line it
goes back blocks and blocks and blocks
and blocks the people that are sitting
that they have the time to sit 45 M an
hour and a half for [__] food it's not
good it's not that good they have two
hours to sit and wait for French fries
that by the by the time they they get
them will will be cold because they've
been sitting
there let give them what they want they
want they want gods and they want
someone to worship they want someone to
worship give them Taylor Swift give them
Taylor and then she can you know she can
really solve a lot of problems that are
haven't been able to be solved
yet
fall in she can fall in and out of love
with migrants and the country will react
to the migrant crisis based on who she's
in love with so if she's in love with
like a North African guy you know who
came over it's like hot but if if she
dumps him no migrants then they get
kicked the [__] out which by the way
toeka Kansas I love how bad they're
doing they're they're literally going
give us migrants Topeka Kansas is going
we've got nothing
left the main industry that Topeka
Kansas had was the Gods uh God hates
[__] church that was their main but it
was their main industry it really was
their main industry was like hate that
was their main thing and they've got
nothing left so Topeka Kansas is
basically telling migrants like Hey
we're we're out here we've got nothing
this article came out I guess it was in
the times or something where Topeka
Kansas is literally advertising for
migrant going please
Kansas Capital hopes to lure migrants
with work all through day how great is
it you're a migrant you just got here
and they're like what about Kansas and
even they know they're like oh I don't
know yeah I don't know about Kansas
while many American cities are
struggling with large numbers of newly
arrived migrants toeka is inviting
anyone and everyone with permission to
work in the US anyone and everyone like
a lot of smaller cities the Kansas
capital is grappling with near stagnant
population growth an unemployment rate
well below the national average and an
unemployment rate well below the
national average according to city and
economic development officials finding
people to fill its roughly 6600 open
jobs has been a struggle so there are
6,000 600 jobs in Topeka Kansas that
people don't want to
fill they don't want to
go for toer mayor Michael
Padia a Democrat and a largely
Republican state the effort to attract
immigrants along with Americans living
in other cities just made sense because
there toeka is coming
out and going we if you are [__]
that's Topeka Kansas and by the way that
could be a good it's really not a bad
way to attract people it's like if you
are F if it didn't work anywhere else
come here did you fail in Austin come to
Topeka did Miami not pan out did you not
ride the Bitcoin wave of Miami to Star
Island it didn't work out you don't live
next to Jared in ianka on Indian Creek
Island come on down to Topeka Kansas
work at a food truck that's nice you
serve a couple of Burly lesbian and
enchiladas every morning come work at a
food truck put the hash brown in the
burrito thank you come work at a food
truck learn all about Native American
fried bread or whatever the [__] they
serve come down to Topeka Kansas live in
hell and there's nothing wrong with that
come live in hell come work the front
desk at the Hilton in Topeka Kansas you
will wish you were back in [__] you
know I I don't even know where the hell
a lot of these people got Libya you'll
be you'll want to go back to Libya when
you were standing and working in the
last remaining Pizza Hut in Topeka
Kansas serving the morbidly obese uh
baseball team at the high school their
fourth Pizza in Topeka Kansas come on
down come on down to Topeka Kansas a a
hollowed out meth
hell and I I like Kansas I'm not saying
anything bad about them really I'm just
stating facts as to what's going on over
there cities with something going on
they can't have all migrants in here
they they just don't want it they don't
want it New York's going we can't do it
Mar's vineyard's like hey man we're a
small island we can't handle this toeka
Kansas go we don't care what you did we
don't care what you did in your country
we don't care rape murder torture come
on down work at a food truck serve this
Burly Les being a chili dog so she can
go to her [__] [__] job working for
the energy plant with Topeka Kansas come
down to Topeka Kansas our biggest
industry was Fred Phelps he's our
national celebrity and our biggest
industry was the God hates [__] church
it was our biggest come on down to and
by the way this is where the migrant
should have to go so they will stop stop
coming eventually they'll go oh it's bad
they go no no no no no no no it is not
good it's not the
movies it is not the
movies have the migrants work at this
new diaper Cafe that we're opening in
Massachusetts have the migrants work in
the new diaper Cafe where adults who
have a diaper fetish a woman is and by
the way I can't for example open a
restaurant I've been trying for so long
but it's so difficult to get a
restaurant off the ground somehow this
[__] has opened and I kid you not a
diaper Spa she has a diaper Spa in a
tiny New Hampshire town so I can't open
a restaurant because of red tape and
regulation but this [__] somehow can
open a diaper spa for perverts in a tiny
little New Hampshire town a diaper Spa
to those of you who don't know if you're
an idiot and you're like some type of
prud an abdl an abdl is an adult baby
diaper lover adult baby diaper lover
it's a diverse Community with various
individuals and their unique wants and
needs the owner said a new Spa catering
to diaper wearing adults who want to
roleplay as young children and what
could go wrong has opened in a small
town in New Hampshire alarming some
local R now by the way how cheap is it
to just open maybe that's why I should
open a I mean this [__] can just open a
diaper
Colony the diaper Spa in Atkinson New
Hampshire says it is an age play
friendly adult diaper
Spa I love the idea of this being
someone's dream you know like she's like
well one day I always wanted to hang out
my own
shingle working for yourself is the
American dream and I believed when I
grew up if I worked hard enough and I
saved enough money and I believed in
myself I could open up a place where
adults who want to wear diapers and
pretend to be children could get
off cuz it is sexual this is clearly
she's like it's a I I'll I'll tell you
my favorite line in this whole article
it's coming up the spa is a safe
judgment free zone well number one uh of
course wait a minute really the diaper
Spa is Judgment free yeah I like how she
just has to reiterate that she's like
don't worry this ain't no country club
we're not looking down on anybody here
we're all in diapers it's a judgment
Free Zone by the way that's how [__]
[__] everybody's gotten about
everything that she has to specify that
this isn't one of those upscale diaper
Spas we're gonna have a real LZ Fair
attitude this is a judgment a safe and
judgment free zone for visitors to
pamper themselves with snacks playtime
Story Time nap time you take the
migrants and you put them in the diaper
Spa they have to watch adults in diapers
in New Hampshire pretend to be babies
you do this you publicize it you but I'm
telling you right now they will just go
to Europe just let them go to Paris we
have in our country and this is a great
thing we have the means to solve the
migrant crisis
we have it bring the people in and give
them jobs at make them go to Topeka
Kansas send them to a little town in New
Hampshire to uh to uh to cradle and rock
a 45-year-old pervert in a diaper do
it the spa is a judgment free Z and this
is for people they're all regular adults
and they want to do playtime Story Time
nap time cuddle time changing time
changing time let the M please God
please let the migrants have to
change a
37y old
adult let make the
migrants change the diapers of these
people and then if the migrants stay
then then they are
citizens oh see can you see if the
migrants will change the diaper of our
very very very very sick people that
live here in New Hampshire if the
migrants are willing to change the
diapers of these very healthy but very
unhealthy people they should get to
stay playtime nap time cuddle time
changing Time coloring nursery rhymes
and sing
alongs sir Services advertising include
quote adult baby diaper lover Nursery
Spa Care at 300 an hour virtual play
dates at 200 an hour and an all day
Premier Spa experience for the little
one inside of you for
1500 in the summer you can play with
your water wings in floaty poolside
picnic under a tree with your teddy bear
play marbles on the patio or swing on
the front porch swinging and serve tea
to your dog on the porch in the winter
we can make snow angels build snowmen
drink hot cocoa from beneath clouds of
whipped cream and sprinkles and decorate
gingerbread men or sugar cookies the
Spa's website
advertises but now think of this I'm
very disappointed in these people in New
Hampshire some residents are not happy
about this can you imagine that some
residents are unhappy about this uh some
residents not that happy um it has a
there's this is a little town it
has a population of about 7,000 people
mother of three Kayla Gallagher told the
Eagle Tribune that she's concerned
because the spa is close to a children's
park and fears that it caters to clients
with a sexual fetish what do you mean
Kayla this is something that I will
never be willing to expose my kids to so
now we will no longer be able to use
that
Park local resident Mike vigata was
against the spa for similar reasons can
you imagine telling Mike vigata about
this what's going on over there they're
adults in diapers they're running around
in diapers over there they're [__]
in these diapers these sick [__] you
got to see where I'm living I'm living
in this place they got a diapers it's a
spa but it's for adults who wear these
diapers and they [__] in them I kid you
not Vinnie I'm telling you from my hand
to God the the people people in here
they're [__] in their diapers and
people are cleaning up these sick [__]
go in there Vinnie they pay 300 an hour
for this they put on a diaper they sing
them nursery rhymes yes it's Mike viglia
I'm against this my name is Mike
viglia Spa owner Dr Colleen
Murphy this is my favorite she goes It's
All About trauma this is by the way this
word trauma this is my favorite one you
know PTSD
trauma like this is going to be this is
going to be hijacked and used
for I mean you have no idea what's
coming by the way the
trauma it's so funny it's like
traumatic this is trauma you're getting
over childhood
trauma it helps them process whatever
trauma it was a lot of times it's
childhood trauma when they were in
diapers or just getting out of diapers
and they want to feel that safety that
they had had before
it listen to this okay um so there are
people now that are upset with
this
um so people are angry and they're
trying to get this shut down or maybe it
hasn't opened yet they're trying to stop
it from opening okay so listen to this
this is my favorite one this is my
favorite one okay so this is the woman
Murphy who's opening the diaper
Spa one of the most common Miss
conceptions about adult baby diaper
lover is the association with pedophiles
perverts and sex offenders she told Fox
News this is not true and this is my
favorite line I have read in any article
so far she goes and I have never
encountered anyone of that nature in my
work really not one not one pervert
ever they while in in a DI whilst in a
diaper being uh rocked to sleep in your
spa you've never encountered one pervert
not even one guy not even one guy in a
diaper you thought was sus not even
one Murphy it seems like you might be
lying I've never even encountered that I
don't not in my work or research but
this is a great point I mean it's like
let's this should be the number one
don't shut this down make this bigger
make this bigger because we got a lot of
migrants that need work so do not shut
this down you need this needs to be this
needs to be uh the size of like a
football stadium there'll be enough
people to fill it don't worry about it
you remove the stigma get them all in
there and the migrants you go welcome to
America I'll go down they're three
blocks away from where I am in New York
City right now I will take them right
here welcome to America welcome to uh do
you want to work at a spa and they're go
yes yes we'll go into a spa good good
get in the car we go right to the spa
and it is um we tell them what it is now
they're not going to understand it
because they come from cultures that are
not as advanced as us with our adult
diaper lover baby cuddle coddle you know
with with the rattle we're GNA say these
are adults because of their trauma
because of their trauma what's your name
inz these are inz let me explain to you
what you'll be doing you're going to be
changing you diapers oh that's good you
love children you have a few okay CZ let
me just break it down a little bit for
you because I know you come from a very
simple culture where people just the
only people who wear diapers are babies
right in El Salvador pretty much right
or or very old people I understand right
right I well we've got something else
going on that's a little different but I
know you're excited to be here and
you're a team player so we just want to
let you know that you're going to be
serving a very important vital function
for a adults who are processing their
trauma by wearing diapers and [__]
in them okay while you rock them to
sleep and tell them nursery rhymes yeah
do you know little B
peep can you imagine that you just got
to America you imagine this you're
coming from like San Pedro Sula in
Honduras or something right you just get
to America okay you're looking at a guy
that looks like me in a
diaper who just [__] in it and you're
reading him little book
[Music]
and you're reading him and you're
reading him little B Peep and you got to
think to yourself how bad was it how bad
was it in
Venezuela you start thinking to yourself
did I have to eat every day maybe I was
being a little bit ridiculous here you
know like maybe that three day a week
where we ate three days a week was
actually fine it's intermittent fasting
I mean that's all the rage you know if
you're looking at a guy like me in a
diaper and you're reading me a nursery
rhyme and I have a like a a what do they
call them the nookie what do they call
the thing oh Binky is it called Binky
but what's the real name for it um the
thing that babies have my godson's over
it now he's three you don't have him
anymore at that age pacifier pacifier
yeah so if I have a pacifier in my mouth
and you're reading me
uh I don't know what's another one
there's little B peep what's another
nurser Cat in the Hat like Dr that's not
a nursery rhyme Cat in the Hat that's
Humpty Dumpty you're reading me Humpty
Dumpty and I'm there in my diaper and
I've got a pacifier in my mouth
I'm and I'm looking at you and you're
from Venezuela or Honduras or any of
these places you got it in your
head can you imagine like the first call
you have with your family at back home
home like the first call you have you
go how is America how is America you go
this K got real problems
here I want to hear Little Bo Peep again
they go there are grown men in diapers
and I have to change them and I have to
read them nursery rhymes and then we
have music
and what else did it say it's like you
can have hot cocoa Under the Stars what
else yeah there's nap time there's uh
nap time yeah nap time what else we got
nap time all the different things
anything a child uh making snow angels
hot coco uh decorate gingerbread men
well it says you can just you can
relieve yourself at will in your diaper
too oh well that's the point of a diaper
well that's of course I mean that's by
the way they don't even have to say that
no they don't even have to say that
you're in a diaper you're going you're
going to use the B how crazy would it be
to wear a diaper and use the can you
imagine that guy who's like no I'm into
the diaper play but I don't want to take
it that far it's like Phil will you stop
going to the bathroom just [__] in your
diaper Phil it feels like you're not
comfortable enough for leaving yourself
in your diaper you keep using the
bathroom yeah well I just you know don't
like the smell Phil
Phil I just want to see these migrants
because you got to prove here's the deal
I'm not against the people that come
into this country for better
opportunities and a better life but they
have to prove they have to prove it and
working at the diaper
Spa is the best way or living in
Topeka they all decide to go to the
diaper Spa they go to topa for five
minutes and go we'll go to diaper Spa
thank you we'll go to diaper Spa but
it's a way to prove you have to prove
your loyalty now to live in this
superpower and you also got to know
where we're headed
we're headed to an interesting
place where everyone's going to be
getting their trauma
out in different ways and I'm not trying
to shame anyone Kink
shame what happened to feet can you just
lick a toe you know what I mean like
isn't that enough for people just lick a
toe God
Jesus what about polyamory can we just
do that just [__] a bunch of different
people can we at least settle on
that can I just request it we just do
that I
guess can we stop it licking a toe how
about that you could feet you got feet
you don't need to be in a diaper all the
time can you imagine what's the
marriages this this thing's
gonna you know the wife says to the
husband goes you seem really tense I
think you should go to diaper Spa John
John listen to me John I want you to go
to diaper Spa I know that's where you've
been going you don't have to hide it I
think you should go you need some time
go to diaper spa and be swaddled you
need to be swaddled in diaper
Spa I can't I just can't I just want to
see the looks on these people's
faces from El Salvador wherever they're
coming North Africa Libya the Middle
East they when they come in in their
diaper
spot and they're wiping the ass of a man
who looks exactly like me and I just
look at them and I would
go
welcome welcome in welcome in I'm
telling you factor is Big this is a big
deal everybody's doing meal prep you
cannot don't let the year get by you
know your all your resolutions are still
intact you still have time it's still
very early in this year Factor's ready
to eat meal delivery takes the stress
out of meal planning and sets you up for
success in the New Year skip the grocery
store prep work and cooking fatigue
instead get Chef crafted dietitian
approved meals delivered right to your
door with over 35 meals to choose from
per week including options like keto
calorie smart vegan and veggie for
somebody like me that's on the road a
lot and for a lot of my friends it's
really a great idea to have a meal
service for many people that have
children and are working and they have
so little time it's really a great idea
to get healthy Chef created meals
delivered right to your door I mean
don't do the takeout folks it's
overpriced it's never as good when you
get it home factor is cheaper and way
more delicious than takeout get Chef
crafted restaurant quality meals
delivered right delivered right to your
door need a special occasion meal
Gourmet plus is the perfect solution if
you're looking for fast upscale options
done easily
when things get hectic factor is flexble
CH flexible change your order every week
with plans from four to 18 meals per
week or pause or reschedule your
deliveries
anytime stress lasts over meal times in
the New Year factors no prep No Mess
meals free up time otherwise spent
shopping cooking and clean up no more
wasting time in the
kitchen I'm telling you head to factor
meals.com Tim D50 factor meals.com
td50 and use the code Tim D50 to get 50%
off that's
crazy Tim D50 that's the coded Factor
you get 50% off go right now get 50% off
your meals try it you're G to love it
I'm telling you right now 50% off that's
one of the craziest sponsored deals that
anyone has ever done take advantage of
it right now Tim D50 Factor meals.com
td50 promo code is Tim D50 50% off roses
are red violets are blue trim your balls
and your date will thank you what's up
fellas Valentine's Day is knocking and
manscaped is a remedy for the love
doctor ordered his prescription the only
new performance package 5.0 Ultra
designed to elevate your grooming game
with without a prescription oh my God I
mean sorry let's do this
again Valentine's Day is coming and you
guys got to get ready and the way to get
ready is
manscaped manscaped is the best I'm
telling you let's talk about the hero of
Valentine's Day the lawn mower 5.0 Ultra
the electric trimmer features skin safe
technology guarding your vday treasure
against any grooming mishaps it also
comes with their brightest LED spotlight
yet it's brighter than your best
romantic smile perfect for precise
grooming even in the trickiest spots oh
it's waterproof too making shower shaves
of Breeze but hey that's not everything
the love doct ordered this package also
features the weed whacker 2.0 nose hair
trimmer manscape liquid formulation and
two free goodies the shed travel bag and
boxers 2.0 because Comfort is King I'm
telling you you got to do it and for a
happy ending there's manscape refine
cologne it's Valentine's Day touch for
your grooming routine elevate your
grooming
routine get 20% off and free shipping
with the code timd manscape.com that's
20% off this is the best product on the
market for this to be honest it is the
best 1,000% nobody regrets getting this
20% off free shipping at manscape.com
you manscape.com use the code Tim D
because you're grooming up greater
weights this guy who beheaded um his
father We we played his
music earlier on the show he's I think a
a rare Talent can I say that can I say
he's a q andon believer accused
beheading federal worker dad smirks in
in new mug shots as it reveals he waged
legal war with government over student
loans now I don't want to get in
trouble and we discussed this
earlier and I don't know what we can do
here I just what can happen here can
anything
happen I'm asking you about this
visual what can happen now I don't even
want to let them know I want to let the
people at the
YT what can happen here well I mean
they've been can I just should I have a
fake head
or but even that I'll get in trouble for
that so we're not allowed to play this
video at all
no simply because there's a human head
in it yes I feel like YouTube is going
to win on this one like I feel like it's
going to be tough for me to even defend
defend this most of what they get upset
at I find them to be a little absurd but
in this case in this rare instance I
will say that I do believe some caution
perhaps is needed because there is a
human head in the video and he holds it
up we can't play it we can play after we
can play when he's talking but the first
20 seconds are are you sure we can do
that um no I mean maybe we just all at
him Bargo him yeah no no show no show
him so we can't play any of this but
here's my problem with this I just can I
from this man's point of view
uhhuh this man goes through the trouble
to cut his father's head off which by
the way is not easy he used two knives
he used a machete and then a large steak
Knife which by the way a lot of these
knives are dull they're not great I'd
love a knife sponsor because I do like
cutting now he C cuts his dad's head off
okay and he puts it in a bag and then he
goes on for about 14 minutes to make
great
points about not all of them but some a
great points about how unaffordable
things are you know he went to all this
trouble and the idea that we can't play
any of this what he
said he's only 32 he's really given his
life he's given up his
life you know and we can't can we read
some of it uh we can read like
transcripts of what he said yeah look at
this America's white mail meltdown
starts with Taylor Swift and ends with
Justin Mahone the Philadelphia Inquirer
the thing that's interesting about um
journalists now so I'm gonna tell you
what's happening in
journalism uh not that you
care
uh journalists now for the most part are
one paycheck away from living on the
street this is true journalists now are
they are their only hope is to go Mega
viral so they have to write these crazy
articles like American white Mill
meltdown starts with Taylor Swift and
ends with Justin mod like ends with this
guy who beheaded his dad and then they
just got a the very public meltdown in
Maga world over the pop star reveals a
more dangerous deadly toxicity embedded
in our society so they just have to
conflate at all these things so they
basically have to be like if you don't
like Taylor Swift or you criticize her
or you say that maybe she shouldn't pick
our president you're you're almost at
the phase where you're going to start
decapitating members of your own family
and they have to
write this now I don't I I don't even
know what this guy said I only heard a
few of what he said I shouldn't say he
made great points I didn't listen the
whole 14 minutes I'm sure he said things
I don't agree
with but the whole thing
is I listen to like three thinks but I
thought he was kind of doing that RFK
thing where he's like you know what I
mean like State Street Vanguard they're
taking all our money I that I get
right so I didn't I thought he was just
doing that kind of kind of that populist
rhetoric which I can everyone can get
behind Vanguard Black Rock I thought it
was more like [__] black rock but
apparently some of it was racist I don't
know but so here's what I
want
[Music]
um listen to this right a white you is
nevertheless a fairy tale that lived on
in the Warped Mind of a young man named
Justin moan retreated into leviton's
Labyrinth inside his parents home on
upper Orchard Drive when his 2014 degree
in Agra bus management from Pennsylvania
state university only resulted in a
series of occasional MC
jobs call center well I
mean like these
people can the media by the way can the
media ever not like be [__] like
there's nothing that these people
they're they're all almost dead the
media they're starving they're laying
them off left and right they can't do
anything they have a MC job you have a
MC job you writing for the Philadelphia
Inquirer that is a MC job so he calls a
MC jobs he goes only resulted in a
series of occasional MC jobs call
centers cubicle Farms a Jersey Mike
Subway shop so by the way if you work
just to give you an give you an idea of
what the this the media what they think
of you if you work at Jersey miks and
you make sandwiches for a living the
media thinks you are scum they think
you're scum if you work at a call center
they think you're scum and if you work
uh at a cubicle Farm whatever that is
guys a data collect your eny so I it's
amazing over that decade moan made it
clear what he blamed for the struggles
that kept him living in his parents
house in his 30s affirmative action
which he believed meant he couldn't
succeed as an overeducated white man
overeducated or not I'm like well deal
with this deal with us moan apparently
did his own research in an interesting
online
existence that included a failed effort
to launch a national militia in a
YouTube
video in his most recent 14 plus minute
production moan ranted against BLM
antifa invasion of immigrants lgbtq
activists
and an overreaching all powerful federal
government you know so here's what so
you have schizophrenics are going to do
crazy things because they are
schizophrenics my mother was a
schizophrenic she never beheaded anyone
by the way so I'm I'm not saying that
mental illness
necessarily uh provides a justification
for evil Behavior but I am saying that
when your synapses are firing but
they're not quite linking up and you
don't have control you have a mental
deficiency and
illness you can get into some bad stuff
and this guy was a psychopath who cut
his father's head
off a lot of people are going to do
things like this and a lot of them are
going to do it for Myriad of reasons
some of them are political social
cultural whatnot that you know there's
going to be these weird manifestos that
these people write and then people are
going to glom on to them and say this
this one proves so what is it you know
this one proves that you know
if if you criticize black lives matter
and this guy criticized black lives
matter well then you're this guy you're
you're cutting heads off you just don't
know it yet you just don't know it yet
this is the exact same way they tried to
beat Trump last
time the way to beat Trump was to let
Trump be Trump and and not go at him not
fight because when he's up against the
ropes he's great he's amazing when he's
up against the ropes he's
skilled but towards the end of his term
and then after his term ended he was
kind of everybody in his inner circle
they were all fighting with each other
and he was kind of you know his fan base
started to kind of desert him a little
bit they went a little bit to DeSantis
there was certainly more consternation
in that world than there
was when you go at him and when you
start charging him with all these
[__] things he's able to very easily
you know he gets the support of his
supporters who feel like they're coming
to his defense this is this is obvious
by the way you could explain this all to
a seven-year-old the way that they tried
to beat Trump last time was to basically
say everyone who's voting for him or
who's even thinking of voting for him is
a Neo-Nazi militia member but they don't
know it yet they don't know it yet it's
not it's stage one or whatever it's not
detectable they don't know it yet but if
we ran all the tests if we did all the
Diagnostics we would find out that they
are card carrying members of the
American Nazi party and that's what they
tried to do and they tried to shame
people they tried to go go aren't you
embarrassed you're a Nazi and don't know
it aren't you ashamed you're a Nazi
white nationalist you don't even know it
and then people go no man I'm really
just concerned about the Border I I
think the econom is not great I I don't
understand 13-year-olds getting uh you
know permanent medical operations when
they're confused you know maybe they
should wait till they get a little older
to transition medically to another gen
no you a Nazi and you don't know it and
people go I don't know man I I'm I don't
think so and this is the the the tack
that they've taken trying to defeat him
it's fails it's always
fails it always fails it's you know
he is very good at at not playing that
their game see in order to beat someone
at a game they have to play it this is
what the media doesn't realize this is
what the the brilliant people in the
media who who ran their own business by
the way into the ground they've ran
their own business into the ground
calling people he couldn't he just he
graduated from the University of
Pennsylvania and he only had a stint of
MC jobs he only had a stint of
mix okay so the reality of the situation
is in in order to be someone in the game
they have to play your game and Trump
doesn't really play that game he doesn't
play he doesn't apologize he doesn't he
doesn't play the game the only way that
it would work is if he were to play that
game and go I'm sorry I didn't really
mean that
or he doesn't play
it so here we go Philadelphia
Inquirer says I keep coming back to
something moan said in his beheading
video where he declared that the flood
of desperate refugees crossing the Rio
Grand is actually an invasion from third
world countries they're coming here with
health issues they're uneducated
unemployed and all they do is commit
crime on the street oh wait I'm sorry
that wasn't the Bucks County beheader
that was the Republican lieutenant
governor of Texas Dan Patrick who was
speaking this week on Fox News and spou
the kind of rhetoric that might inspire
a m militia well also this week
obviously not every immigrant comes
across the border committing crimes we
know that but by the way has any
politician not been prone to like
overstatement and I per that's all they
do that's all they do this week There's
a video I don't know if you have it or
certainly a photo of it of migrants
attacking the NYPD
because we don't know who the [__] these
people are that came into America I do
know that they're going to work at the
diaper
Spa this is literally from
NYPD they're there and the migrants
attack the
nyp are we are we saying that none of
the migrants will commit any crime is
that the goal
here and I'm not trying to agree with
the guy who beheaded his F I'm against
beheading your
parents can I go on the record
can I go can I go on the record and say
that I'm against beheading your
parents I'm against it I'm also against
living in ltown Pennsylvania I'm against
a
lot if if my son made that song play the
second song we played not the
first if my son made this s do you know
how far away I'd want to be from him if
I heard this song coming out of my son's
room imagine you have a kid you're not
my son why Mom
you're
the you hear that one day you're going
about your business you're getting cold
cuts you're getting cold cuts what's the
Pennsylvania Supermarket I don't know
don't look it up it doesn't matter the
point is
whatever Kroger is Ohio I
think here's my
point Pennsylvania you're getting a cold
cuts out you know you get to Turkey you
get the Cracked Pepper turkey B's head
can you sponsor me if I'm going to do it
for free if I'm going to put it out for
for free you get the Cracked Pepper
turkey out the Boar's Head you get the
sliced white American cheese don't be an
animal get the white and you put it out
you got some nice wheat maybe some wheat
and then you're go walk up to your son's
room because you want to knock on his
door because you're about to make some a
sandwich which will be the honey wheat
which is white bread but it's a
different color it's the same thing
wheat bread is fake but that's neither
you nor there you take the honey wheat
you put the turkey on it some white
American cheese some mayonnaise some
Cracked Pepper and maybe if it's a
summer you get some sliced tomato don't
do tomato in the winter if it's got the
white in the middle don't do it and
lettuce number one is not the type of
lettuce you're going to buy isn't really
great for you anyway a rugula gets stuck
in your teeth and the lettuce when it's
on a burger or a sandwich the food just
slides off so stop putting that iceberg
lettuce on the burger unless you shred
it because if you put a wedge of iceberg
lettuce on the the whole Burger it's
everything slides off the
bun as you're making your sandwich which
is if you're smart Cracked Pepper uh
turkey white American cheese
mayonnaise wheat bread and um who knows
maybe a little avocado whatever is in
season you walk up to your son's room
because you will are also and you put a
little potato salad a little macaron
salad as well with that and you're
you've made a nice plate for yourself
and you think you know what I love my
son I love my son and I you know he went
to Penn State he work hard and now he's
working at some call center he's having
a rough go of it but I love him so much
I've just made this meal for myself I'm
gonna give it to him I'm gonna offer it
to him and I'll make myself another one
I'm gonna say you know what do you want
and you go and you hear this by you
[Music]
goly
roing at that point when you hear that
you're you're are filled with a a
there's a coldness in your chest because
you realize something very bad you don't
know what it is but you just here's what
happens when you hear that you walk
right back to the your Center Island
okay your Center island with granite
still Granite huh but
granite and you sit down on your granite
Center Island and you eat the sandwich
in silence and you are really terrified
because you know this woman came home
and found her
husband's headless body in the
bathroom and by the way I wouldn't even
try this case I would just say ladies
and gentlemen of the
jury the piggy piggy make your head
feeling
dizzy aren't I part of this family or
everyone so here's what's interesting
about this guy this guy's kind of like
a what's interesting he's an interesting
archetype person he seems kind of like a
musical theater gay militia guy like
that seems what he is no what is this
like he's that's musical theater he's
doing like you
know silly silly come and kill me the
CIA runs all our cities and this is that
I mean there's something going on here
with this guy that he um but no when you
hear something like that coming out of
your son's room who's however old 32 you
say to yourself you go hey man man I
mean this is like
[__] this is not good and and you got
to get you got to
move can you play the neighbor the
neighbor had a great reaction to this
because the neighbor is basically just
like Judy let's play Judy's reaction
today you just don't wake up in the
morning and think you know I think I'm
going to I think I'm going to cut his
head off give me a little something to
do today you know I I I can't even
believe that that could happen but it
happened the nearly unspeakable event
happened at 700 p.m. Tuesday when
Middletown Township police were called
to the 100 block of upper Orchard Drive
in the Lev toown section to find the
victim 68-year-old Michael moan
decapitated in the downstairs bedroom
according to court documents in a nearby
bedroom the victim's head was found in a
clear plastic bag set in a cooking pot
it just makes you aware of you know the
issues that are prevalent in our our
society and um you know it's it's it's a
horrible tragic incident investigators
learn of a video posted to YouTube by
the victim's 32-year-old son Justin in
which he rails at the federal government
and lifts his father's severed head to
the camera tracking his cell phone
police Trace moan to Fort Indian toown
Gap nearly two hours away driving his
father one of the worst things about the
story is the father can't retell the
story you know how great it would be the
the father to retelling the story is
like my son cut my [__] head off he
cut my head my son cut my I wonder how
he did it I guess he killed his dad
first I don't want to get too gruesome
here but he did it he did it he did it
he he he decapitated his father he cut
his father's head
off can you imagine
that I was sitting down to somebody
today were having coffee in Brooklyn B
is so severe everyone the energy there
everybody's like these white people you
know this this comic this guy Jeff
really funny comedian I started with
used to say that people in Brooklyn all
act like um extra or they all dress like
extras from The Wire season 2 like
they're all Dock Workers Kart and
everything and all these like people
like the type the strain of
like you know intellectual pursuit in
Brooklyn it's it's it's all very heavy
and severe and none of these people look
like they're having fun and every coffee
shop has like a sign that says end
racism it's like now now while I'm
eating my scone and you're just sitting
there and all these people are they're
all reading books or they're on their
MacBooks and they're you know typing
away furiously and everybody seems angry
and mad right and I was uh talking to
someone I was telling them I'm like I
haven't been around in a bit like i' I
I've just been on the road a lot and
I've lived in La uh and on and off Texas
whatever and I spent time in Florida New
York whatever and even when I'm here I'm
not here I'm here briefly and you know
it's just funny cuz I I I I forgot
how
severe that in environment could be like
and and it just seemed like one of those
places where like they put up the
hostage posters and people rip them down
it felt like that's all they did all day
I feel like no one there had a job
except putting up hostage posters and
ripping them down I feel like that was
the like the Jewish hostage poster goes
up and then somebody rips it down and
and that's what what I felt like it was
and I was reading about this guy while
being there and it was and I was reading
about
his behavior and it was you know was
just very I I had to take a walk I'm
like this is very heavy I'm in this
coffee shop and everybody's heavy and
I'm reading about this guy and he's and
it just feels you know felt like there
was heaviness all over but the person I
was with was I was talking to them about
this and
they were like I'm surprised this
doesn't happen more often it's always
someone that says I go what what
what I just don't understand I think
people really I think people think that
everyone who disagrees with them is is
is capable of this and that's the
problem we have now is that I don't
think everyone I say everyone in
Brooklyn's severe and a bit annoying I
don't think they were beheading people I
don't think they're all but it was just
interesting the way they said that they
were like I'm surprised this doesn't
happen more I'm like you're you're
surprised people don't cut their
father's heads off in a bathroom more
often really I was kind of surprised at
this one I was kind of shocked at this
you're telling me that you're not
surpris you're like you're what's
surprising to you about
this uh Brooklyn guy you're surprised
that this isn't happening on the day on
The Daily like every day somebody's not
hacking their dad's head off how what
kind of world or we have we created that
someone's like oh they had that story
where he cut his dad's head off
surprised that doesn't happen on the
hour you go really and I don't know if
that's something people just saying to
seem tough or hard or cynical or like I
don't know man like I I I understand a
fraction of what he's saying to a degree
because I've said versions of it but it
was really rooted in this idea that like
well yeah well he lives in Pennsylvania
and he you know he's he doesn't think
you know he doesn't believe the things I
believe aren't all those people Killers
they're all killers they just don't know
it
yet um and then the MK Ultra people like
this guy's been activated right that's
the other part of the
internet I haven't looked into it I'll
they'll accuse me they like he's the
Sheep I haven't looked into
it I haven't looked into it folks I
don't I don't know I don't know I I
close the door on nothing by the
way the only thing I'm certain of is
that Sandy Hook
happened and get me and get me with my
monies my
monies no but I always believe Sandy
Hook happened you know I I the only
issue I had with Sandy Hook is they were
describing it as a as a really wealthy
community and I was like it's not
greenage that was my main issue was the
classification
of but by the way quick little update on
the GG Gilbert goons uh they're all
getting rested now
we'll cover I broke the story I'm
responsible for the Justice happening
but I'm not taking credit for it because
I'm not that guy I'm not the guy that
runs around and goes hey look at me look
at all the good stuff I do look at me
solving murders in my spare
time no but I am the person that called
National prominence to it and attention
I think many people know that I think
many people know that
and um the chips are falling they're
starting to
fall one of the main SU they just put
their house up for rent
supposedly I don't know I check in on
this Reddit like five minutes a night I
just read whatever the Reddit says the
people on the Reddit now have gone
completely insane the people on the
Reddit now are like it's the it's kind
of like storylines from Breaking Bad on
the Reddit I'm like guys I don't I just
read it I think they've all lost their
mind like it's it but they are the ones
who got anything going so they are
emboldened by the that this
citizen sleo thing activism whatever you
want to call it is what got the wheels
of Justice in motion so I understand but
then there's people there that have
completely lost their minds and they're
they're like this is deep this goes this
cartel it's deep it's it's like no it's
not what cartel what
folks
um you
know I wonder if any of the goons have
listened to my episode with
theovon he's got a lot of young fans my
episode is being very well received
because it's a great episode one of the
funniest episodes of anything I've ever
done are the gilber goons
listening perhaps Tim Dillan comedy.com
we have a massive announcement coming up
by the way we have a massive
announcement that I don't even think I
can
announce I'm not gonna announce
it go to my website timc comedy.com you
see where I'm performing I'm not going
to read the whole
thing I'm not going to do it if you're
that dumb I'm not trying to convince the
dumbest people on the in the
world like CIA will be like well you
asked it too because some people can't
read I'm like well then I don't want
that well then they don't have to come
they don't have to come if they but if
you are like Blinder something there I
there's other ways to find out if you're
blind DM me I'll tell you a word I'm
performing the point is I have a huge
announcement about a European tour a big
deal we're going to spend the spring
some of the spring in
Europe and we're doing one of the the
most amazing iconic venues in the world
I'm very excited about it but let me
just do it for to be nice The Pageant St
Louis Missouri Indianapolis West nyak
New York Boston
Massachusetts um Foxwoods in Connecticut
shamberg Illinois uh Dania Beach Florida
San Jose California uh Port Chester New
York Atlantic City New
Jersey and lots of uh stuff happening
we've got new merch being announced kind
of really fun and then we also have a
very big European tour
announcement
UK as well so um we do appreciate you
listening uh we're on patreon every week
as well give the country to Taylor Swift
let Taylor
Swift be the Arbiter of justice for this
man who beheaded his father he should be
presented he should be presented and
Taylor Swift should be had him in the
middle of the Super Bowl Stadium with
Travis KY and she should hold his head
up and she should go ahead for ahead and
everybody goes nuts because why not
everybody loves Taylor Swift I bet
they're gonna play her music on Loop in
the diaper Spa